Now what if we're writing JSON? Well the function for writing
JSON is called dumps. And just like we had, loads, this stands
for dump string. If we just use dump in Python that
would expect a, a file argument so we're writing it directly to
a file. But we'll be just be using dumps. And you
can pass into dumps a Python object, in this case let's just
say one, two, three, a list. And dumps will convert that to
JSON for us. Let's go ahead and see that in the terminal.
You can see I didn't put quotes around this, because this is
the actual list object we've converting to JSON. It outputs a string,
that's what these quotes are, of the JSON representation, which looks almost
identical. That's pretty cool, huh? And if we were to make this object
a little bit more complicated, map the string "one" to the number
1 and "two" to the number 2, we get our JSON. Now, the
order changed, because order is not defined in dictionaries, but we get
our JSON. Now, let's see where escaping comes into play. If I were
to, instead, print the string two, we ought to make
this string the man said cool. What would dumps do? So
what I did is I changed the value for the,
the, the two key to a string. Remember, these single quotes
are delineating the string. And then, the string has an
internal section with double quotes in it. Our JSON library will
escape that for us. And you can see here that
it is printing out a Python string that is valid JSON.
And the Python version of the string has double quotes in it.
I mean, double slashes in it. You need to be careful because this
is not, in itself, valid JSON. This is valid Python representing valid
JSON. That's why you have these double slashes. So you need to be
careful when you are copying and pasting code, you know, or copying
and pasting JSON, and it's in and out of Python that you get
the escaping right. If I were to take this and instead print
it so you can see the actual value, we'd just have the single
backslashes which is the actual valid JSON, so. Time for a
quick little quiz. Okay. What is the valid JSON representation for
this Python data structure? So this is Python code. We'll include
text version of this so you can copy and paste it into
your editor. And I'd like you to put in this text
box what the valid JSON version of this is. Basically, I'm
testing the, your ability to use the JSON module, and have
it escape properly. Now remember, I don't want to see the Python
version of the JSON string. I want to see
the actual JSON string, that if you were sending
this over the wire to somebody that would
be interpreted properly by the JSON reader. Good luck.